hey what's up guys my name is cheono
what you're about to watch is an uncut
video of me making the music for ludum
dare 30. so if you guys don't know what
latin dare is it's basically an event
where you have 48 hours to make a game
from scratch right and all games need
music so i take the time to write some
music for it so this video is completely
uncut right from scratch this is this is
going to be from me having no idea of
what even genre i want to write the
music in to starting to get some ideas
um and all the way up to the finalized
production right the whole thing um
uncut as well there's not one single
edit in this video this is pulled right
from the twitch.tv live stream um where
i live streamed this during the
competition all right
now in terms of how we did
in latin dare i think we got like around
number 400 overall which isn't too bad
considering um latin dare 30 for me was
all about learning a web technology
right so i i basically had never written
a
a decently sized application in
javascript before and i just thought you
know what i want to learn how to make a
game in webgl for the internet that runs
natively inside a web browser so that's
what happened right i didn't know any of
it and i came out with a playable game
right which i thought was a great um
little achievement now
audio wise though we won we got number
one in the audio category well i got
number one in the audio category for
lotto 30 which just blows my mind
because the game had no audio apart from
the music right so i don't even know
what happened there but um i didn't have
time for that but
honestly the music isn't even it's it's
i'm not gonna say it's bad
um because i shouldn't say that it's not
but it's very rough right most of most
of the there's like three tracks most of
them are basically just a one it was
just a one take kind of me playing right
because i didn't have time to go through
it um but apparently i mean a lot of
people liked it so i'm really glad um so
yeah we came number one in audio which
was amazing so what you're about to
watch is um
the the music that led up to that one
more thing as well you'll see me kind of
lean in from time to time into into like
what looks like the camera but i'm kind
of looking right past it that's me
reading the chat okay because this was
streamed on twitter tv so i was reading
all the comments and i was making sure
the live stream was actually working so
that's that's why i lean in and go
silent okay and there are a few times
where i'm just silent for about two
minutes reading comments and why not so
just deal with that all right but anyway
enjoyed the video hope you guys enjoyed
the music if you want to see more music
follow me on soundcloud for
soundcloud.com
the channel and i'll see you guys soon
goodbye
okay how does this work hopefully this
will work now this internet is much
better than the one in my bloody
apartment so
i don't think we'll have any problems
but i'm gonna just make sure that
everything's running good
and is
it
i think it might be
yeah it looks very good actually the
quality looks amazing
all right
so i need to open the chat
twitch.tv
thatcher now all right here we go
pop out the chat
i'll just i'll just get this around me
and watch myself i guess
right okay um
so
sorry i need to actually set up a few
things so i'll be right back
hmm
that light is pretty bright isn't it
hopefully won't be too bad
you guys can hear me all right yeah
how's it lagging
is the stream actually lagging
hang on it shouldn't be
it's not lagging on my computer and i'm
watching it so
maybe it's too high quality for you guys
it's not lagging on my end so
if you guys could tell me if it's
lagging or not
since i'm i'm literally watching the
stream on twitter and it's fine
so
yeah it's not lagging
okay it's not lagging good
all right
so
this
these are my
yeah i know it's grainy that's because
it's low light and this is my micro pros
camera that's all right so the idea
behind this the fighters disappear
behind new earth and i have to zoom out
yeah i know anyway um
in terms of what like the music design
for this i think what i want to go for
is
um
i better plug in my map yeah hold that
thought
yeah so
as i was saying
um
what i think the music design for this
will be
is
kind of what it's set in space and it's
like a space rts where i i want it to be
you know mystical
kind of weird
so i'm thinking something to do with
like
guitar like intense amount of like
reverb and just really
wacky i don't know maybe
um and some kind of like strings in
there as well
i think
i mean we're just gonna see we're gonna
try a bunch of stuff and see what
happens i don't have too much time here
obviously but we'll see what we can do
so
i have no idea where i'm gonna put this
actual computer because no matter what i
do you guys aren't gonna be able to see
unless i prop it up i've got an idea
actually
i could
put it on this
and that might be a bit better
so
hopefully
this will just let you guys see me a bit
more so i don't keep moving the camera
oh yeah
yeah that good i'll throw up
unfortunately
yeah
okay great fantastic
oh that was good enough um
do something like let it go yeah no um
okay
so probably
this for this
um
but we are going to need something to
record the cam
yeah ambient something ambient kind of i
think i'm probably gonna record the amp
with this i don't really have a good
instrument mic i should get one
but we'll use this for now
it's more of a vocal kind of recording
mic but it'll do
so i'm just going to um
i i
have nothing to
attach it to
because that's at my other place
fantastic
that's not
good once we hang it from something
hmm
yeah i don't know what i was thinking
yeah okay we'll have to like suspend it
in the air
not good
that's all right there
i forgot i've got an adapter for it but
it's not here
so this is a really good
really high production value improv here
we're going to be hanging this
microphone
from this
like just like so
i mean it it doesn't get i don't know if
you guys can see that all right but
it doesn't get much better quality than
this
what if i turn off this slide because
that's just literally
like
i don't know if that'll be better
that looks better i think it's better
so that's that's gonna be our technique
our
just i made i'm gonna take this off
amazing technique for recording
the app here
all right
okay that's good
i'm gonna assume that's all good
i'm gonna have to i'm not gonna be able
to read the comments too often i'll have
to lean in to see them but
that's all right
okay so
let's
give the amp a bit of time to warm up
meanwhile i'm gonna
turn on so what you guys can't see is
over here i've got
a bit of a setup going on as well
there's a really old
2000
2010 macbook pro
like underneath this this little
desk thing
um and i use that with what with logic
pro
with um yeah so mac logic pro and that
that's how i that's the software i'm
going to be using basically all right
for you all you for all you music people
out there
who are wondering oh i'm using
okay
all right
i think we're good
i am pretty tired yeah i'm not tired now
wake up
let's do this all right
so
probably gonna use this guitar
hopefully it's in tune
all right
so now
i need to pick
all right
where are my picks
yes
it's where i left one here
it's all good i found one
okay
all right
clear some of this stuff here
why not running on an extremely limited
time here unfortunately
otherwise i could probably spend like
all of them there doing this
but um hopefully
we'll have time to make something
and we got sound
all right you guys hear that all right
probably well i mean it's not too loud
that's what i meant i don't think it is
i mean
sounds all
okay now unfortunately that's not the
sound for space so i'm probably going to
put it through a bunch of effects pedals
to get some nice
to get some nice like
kind of reverb ambient
sort of tunes
so
let's set that up
okay
that's the output
let's return
all right
no that's not a press stage
i'm not i'm not that rich it's a um it's
like a it's an ibanez rg250
um which is really good for the money by
the way all right anyway um
now we should get some effects
so what i've got on the ground for those
of you can't see
and who want to see
is um
nothing too special
just a um
it's a it's a line six pod hd 300
and
i'm running
the amp and whatnot through it
so we're going to change that to clean
for the amp
take it off standby
okay so now we've got some effects gone
from that
harmonics as well
i'm just going to find roughly i don't
have too much time to design this
obviously so i'm just going to find a
rough preset
that is kind of cool
i love the kill repeating
this as well
especially with the tone turned down
i love this effect as well i made this
um like a few months ago
this could be like a nice ambient sort
of thing
what are you guys saying
i feel like a cool bass line for this
i don't know um
it has to be really nice and tony and
like i'll put the tone back up
it has to be slow paced as well so
so maybe like really fast tremolo
picking or something
i don't like that idea as well
space jazz
no that's too high it has to be solemn
i'm gonna sound like something out of
bioshock
all right see a falcon
all right anyway um
now honestly though i think i want to
stick with something like that
and put like a nice bit of techno
babble
onto that
but
basically
i'm gonna kind of
start with the piano here a bit just
because um
they're definitely going to be some kind
well i like piano for working out
melodies all right
it just makes more sense to me than
guitar once i got the melody guitar is
awesome for creating riffs and chords
and whatnot
but until then
so what was i working with there that
was a as a d right no that was
i had it i'd kind of like an e a day c
kind of progression gone
so
uh sounds too too simple
maybe simple is good though
i don't know i really want to somehow
bring up these comments though honestly
a minor seven chord
why what is with you guys in the a minor
seven chord
that sounds too like
i don't know i don't know
that sounds like i'm about to like
seeing a really old kind of jazz
song like
like um
there's once a guy called cherno
etc
so
this just has to be weird
do
oh another kind of sad cheering goddamn
i'm out of this
all right
like mystique
all right no time so finally melody
decided that's what it's going to sound
like now to produce it
what do you guys think of that
oh it's a lot of doggies in the comments
it can't be good
okay now you're gonna
i don't know it's gonna be a while of me
just looking at you guys but that's
because i want to see what you guys said
all right
well i mean
honestly
i mean we don't have all day and it's
already i've felt like half i've got
like an hour left so
maximum otherwise i'm not gonna have
time to finish everything so
so we're gonna have to just roll with it
all right so i don't think we're going
to
do it should we record piano
like properly
or should we just
yeah let's let's record piano properly
let's not midi it will midi the strings
and whatnot
let's be quick though
um
oh another pick good
what's my computer
it did open on the ice cream
all right
the only problem with recording the
piano is um all this stuff on it
i'll get rid of that quickly
don't have much time to write this
symphony
or rather it's basically already written
it's gonna produce it
i don't know if you guys need me talking
but
i'm just gonna see me again
all right here it goes
i wish i had a proper adapter for this
microphone
like stand wise
because it's just hanging right now as
you guys can see
this is probably not the best major
chord piano
for all of you guys who are looking for
tips on whatnot
but hey
i'm the channel
so we're just gonna lower this guy in
there
let's see what happens
oh it's like a crane
e
all right let's just record a bit and
see if
it works like remotely well
because if it does we're all good oh you
guys can't see that
oh you can kind of but that should make
it better
i'm going to just hang out with you
so that's just
all right good
let's just record this roughly
how does that sound
that sounds very good
so i'm now going to turn off
oops now i'm going to turn off these
noisemakers
so we can be in peace
so that we can
make everything silent and record it
without
noise okay nothing else is creating
noise
amps on standby
any final thoughts
ah
okay oh whoa it's slowly falling in
there
not what i wanted
can i stop it from doing that is that
possible
i'm gonna destroy this mic
why is it not
okay there we go
now is it possible
two
i'll probably have to just pull this in
a bit to counter the white
but then i can't really
get it in there
the difficulties
the difficulties
all right how's this
that's pretty good
except it's like the other way around
let's try this
stay like this
you know what that'll do i mean
we're not recording an orchestra here
let's just do a tag and see what happens
well it's recording
wish me luck
thanks
all right i made a mistake a bit there
so that card threw me off of it
that was just improv as well so
unfortunately i don't remember what i
played because i didn't really follow a
pattern
so that's the bad thing about improv
and i think it was a bit too quiet
can i listen to it now
and just uh see if i can
yeah it was really quiet the recording i
should have turned the mic up a bit
i'm just going to kind of brainstorm
some ideas
and tune my guitar
to the piano
so
all right
so
so
all right so that was a bit too quiet
so how does it go e minor
and see
okay
there's a lot of bees in there
that's actually a save but
i don't know i don't know what we could
do with that let's record let's get the
final piano track down
and then we'll um
i'm not creating an orchestra i'm being
an orchestra get it right guys come on
all right
take two
now first of all let's test the
that might piano that peak i think
i did pick
let's try that again
i just want to make sure that i don't
have to record this because it doesn't
work
ah looks good
maybe it's a bit quieter
all right good we're ready to go
this off again
this recording on
all right
good recording's gone
take two
so
so
um
so
and that's a wrap
all right i'm just gonna roll with it i
don't care
i don't have time
probably barely hit the last part on the
recording actually
but that's the piano track wrapped up
i'm sorry i can't
work on it more
i've only got 45 minutes left
all right let's have some effects with
this baby
so what do you guys think of that
acceptable
hopefully
rap
nah i'm not a big i'm not a fan of rap
all right comments yeah
good yeah i know i kind of
i just you know what i thought of while
i was doing the whole
uh up here
i thought of just like the theme of like
tick-tock and that like time is running
out you know like our time is running
out except actually in the game
um so like the time is running out
there's like with the whole earth thing
like it's really tragic because the
people are gonna die
because the time's running out like for
them to move
into the new planet
so
there's a tragic theme in this as well
and i like the whole tick tock thing
if you know what i mean
so yeah
just um i just kind of kind of thought
of that
so that that's why i got carried away
with the last part because i was like oh
it's actually pretty sad
again i know every piece of music i
write is at least a little bit emotional
but yeah
because there is no more garlic bread
yes good point all right so let's add
some effects to this to make it sound
better because it wasn't recorded very
well
um
so eq
compression
so eq eyes let's get to a good juicy
part of the song
but
uh
delay
so i definitely want some delay in there
so it
definitely goes into line there which is
good
no i i raise the bass not because i'm
actually not one of those razor bass
whenever possible kind of guys i raise
the bass because i want to have less
color i want it to be more solemn i
don't want the tone to be as clear
because it's spacey that's why and
so two more things this really needs is
compression obviously to get the
recording to sound a bit better
and then um
so there's some compression on it now
oh sorry
all right that's great let's put that
first though
and we've got some reverb
happening
very wet kind of
brief
not too though
so let's see what it sounds like when
it's
good
i don't know what i'm gonna do guitar
wise
all right no actually the guitar could
go well with the current effect that
i've got on it
which is that intense reverb
so let's try that out
it could go well with this actually
all right
so obviously we won't have anything here
or anything
we could have that sort of thing going
do
i think i think there'll be a lot of
palm muted kind of stuff here
what's that like
so
then
um
so
i'm missing that damn
so that's one of the ways i could kind
of
alright so it ends here
um
one of the tapes right
alternatively we could do like a um
oh glean isn't a bad effect i actually
hate it though
there's some distortion to this
through the amp
not too much
it's very sensitive
so
one of the alternatives i think
now the answer
the amp is a dsl100h
foreign
yeah okay i think i'm just going to do
tapping on this because um with this
effect it's incredibly it's incredibly
sensitive so
so it actually works pretty well with
tapping
it work really well with harmonics as
well
all right
let's do a let's do a tag
so to do a take we should turn this off
oh but then i'm not gonna hear it
that's a problem i need headphones i'll
be right back
mm-hmm
all right
got some astros
i can now
hear it as i play
all right
um
now this is going to be a bit difficult
to record
i'm not gonna lie
just because it's going to be so loud as
well
what else
i need to get like some sure sm57s but i
have any so
that's the cable from the headphone like
the touch of the strings
sounds beautiful
okay so let's just
let's just make sure that
it records all right
yeah it's beautiful
beautiful strong word but
it works all right
and we're live
so
cut that out
all right
i don't know what that was
i know you guys didn't hear that but
obviously it did in my headphones sounds
pretty good i think
um
i think we'll just do like drums and
whatnot now
a bit of a beat
so we gotta wrap it up
i don't think we'll have a um
like a rock kind of feel to it
like with
or something
because i just don't think that like a
nice
yeah i don't think that'll sound great
all right
sounds like a stringed instrument very
funny
all right so this is what it sounds like
i think i'm done looking tough
now that was the take two
meanwhile i'm gonna think up of a
drumbeat
so
it's right here
so
i found a good drum kit
okay
come on
i think i might just have to affect this
[ __ ] like just drop a bunch of effects
on this oh that won't sound nice
that will sound very similar
so which one
please
a lot of river
for spacey
and
also uh
delay
just a bit there
like not that
that sounds good
yeah i know drums on the doorstep agreed
maybe i should have some sweet vocals to
this as well if you guys think of some
lyrics
we can get it done all right here we go
so
that is the most out of beat thing i've
ever recorded but i think it might work
because of the genre of
spacey
crap
i mean i don't know man like
head over there
it'll do i'm not even gonna have time to
listen to it all but we're gonna release
it so
get ready uh i don't know about the
start though with the drums
yeah
yeah what else
i don't think there's too much happening
there's really only three tracks
i don't think i need i don't think i
need strings though i think i'm pretty
much done
man on to under schedule as well
i know i'm gonna check one thing
all right anyway
okay um okay so what do you guys think
get rid of the drums really
i love the drum sounds
no i was joking about the miracles
there's no time i don't want to fit
all right i'll i'll load the drums
it sounds pretty good to me like in real
life i don't know what the how the
microphone is going to pick it up
but um
it's still primarily a piano tracker
see that's like the climax
let's see the end is still all
just like that if you can hear that
and
the start is also very much like that i
mean there's a bit there's a few like
guitar kind of you know hits
at the start but that's about it
anything else how can i just master it
and release it
man that was a good session took like an
hour
pretty good
yeah at the start all the drums yeah
kind of dead um
yeah man i think um what about bass yeah
kick hey i'll put a bass guitar
somewhere
yeah i don't see it
oh it's right there
um
but i don't think i don't think i kind
of like it right now i'm just gonna
listen to it once all right and
if it's good it's it's good we'll roll
with it
we'll get rid of that yeah
so
where does the piano start
so bar eight
measure eight
and when does this start
i'll put we'll make it start here
so this is how it rolls
there we go
so
so
the
the fretboard slides sounds so cool
and then like
the drums here a bit weird i think
oh that's nice
feedback
how did you read
um
yeah
i think i think that's it honestly i
don't think i want to touch it
i think it's pretty good like the way it
is
and i think
bear with me right
that's the wrong button from computer
um
i think
that
because of the game and because of the
fact that earth is being evacuated right
and everyone's rushing everyone's just
losing their mind
the imperfections in the track are
actually a good thing
like
i could spend another hour actually
making it
perfect but
i i
hey i don't have time but b
i actually think i don't want to do that
at all
because
because i don't think it needs that
i think it's i think the imperfections
in the track are just a testament to how
man i could write an essay on this but
seriously this is i should put this on
like this isn't the kind of music i
should vlog to shouldn't shouldn't it be
not like the game because the game's not
really done
well now i better go home and make the
game be as good as the music
yeah all right well
that was a good hour's work
let's move that to the beginning
the mix sounds good i mixed it while we
well
while people while while you guys are
listening to it
i think it's pretty good i don't think
um
oh
do not record over tracks jenna
how's the end
the end's grey all right and yeah
yeah the drums are weird at the end but
i think because
because of the fact that it's weird it's
kind of cool
i'm probably gonna like um
i'm probably i'll what i'll do is i'll
yeah i'm done with this so oh i better
save it first of all it's still untitled
hmm don't want the computer to crash um
names
names
evacuate done
i'm really like slack with naming my
tunes
so i've saved it now
please don't crash good i don't think
logic's ever crashed on me to be honest
now we'll um
bounce it
bounce
i'll pop it up on my soundcloud or
something so you guys can see it i need
do i have a soundcloud account i don't
think i do i'll pop it up there though
as soon as i can export it
so we'll go mp3
uh what bar do i want it to go to 129 no
i think so
what i sure
all right it's exporting i'm done with
it
it's a rude sandstorm
yeah i should add some garlic like
vocals to it
all right
okay i actually want to give one more
measure too
please
fight what
hang on a minute
oh 103.12.
all right
potato
i said potato
have fun
thanks guys i like my little goatee as
well
that's why i've still got it
all right
where are we
oh this is up beneath here that's that's
the last one
that was the last one dad's music
all right there we go
yeah brackets is a great idea
all right let's go
i need a usb though
yeah that's not good how do i get it
from that computer
to this
computer that's difficult
um
damn i really don't have a usb anymore
oh actually yeah
found it
um
oh
i feel that that mac can barely
recognize that usb for some reason
pineapples are cool i do like pineapples
and i do think they're kind of cool so
they are cool so
there you go
all right
so hopefully i can export it
i can get onto this usb
god this screen is so terrible compared
to the retina
yeah it's like a world different those
right this is so fast
oh man how do i use this
it's pretty cool there actually not that
bad
now work usb come on i need to transfer
this
come on
sometimes it'll oh i can just use
airdrop
that's great
i can just use airdrop
all right i've got it
that took like two seconds typing in
itunes now
if this works
i'm done
it does
so
i think the drums need to be lifted just
a bit
well i'm gonna rebounce it with um
i don't know if you guys heard that or
not but
okay how does this sound
i'm still not loud enough
let's try that
i'm just getting the mix right so that
it sounds good on like this laptop at
least
not not on the
pa speakers
yeah that's good
and there it is
all right
we're good
oh i've still got rick and morty open on
my other rick and morty such a guitar by
the way if you guys haven't watched it
check it out all right
um
all right guys uh i'm about to wrap this
up yeah i am wrapping it up um
that's the music done for the game
now to finish the game
implement the music and
i don't even know dude
like
i've got an hour to finish this game
somehow
uh the show is called rick and morty
rick and morty fantastic show
yeah it's an amazing show
so good so hilarious
all right let me quickly um
sort this out quickly
i'm just gonna have to do one thing you
guys wash my face while i do it
all right
all right all right
such a master's room
ah this is being ridiculous
oh i'm tired
this is unbelievable
that's finally
all right
okay i know you guys probably getting
really annoyed
uh
i'm staring at me
all right
yeah i'm just i'm putting on soundcloud
and i think it's up so
yay
all right
you guys can do whatever you want with
the track well not really but i mean you
can listen to it
um here is the link
all right i'm gonna end the stream there
um and i'll see you guys in like 20
minutes i'll start swimming again
probably i need to grab some dinner as
well actually but
um
yeah
uh so yeah thanks for watching i'll see
you guys
in about
20 maybe 30 minutes max
right here all right
all right ladder guys
goodbye and enjoy the track